so with this whole nice game right I
mean you know the dice there's they say
there's people that are professional
with dice I had a friend here a Richard
Turner they call him the card mechanic
so he knows how to manipulate cards
right and you look at him the way he
shuffles you would have been like it's
impossible what he does do you know guys
that you play with that are also you
know magicians when it comes down to the
dice and is that can you read it do you
see people that know how to do that
yeah just well I wouldn't call them
magicians I would call them crooks but
yes I actually had a couple of personal
stories one of them was in Monte Carlo
beginning of like two thousand five or
six I was one of the newbies there came
and start playing for money and actually
beat a couple of guys probably wrong
guys at the time for money and then some
other guy just bump into me
in the end of in a very posh hotel and
start talking talking to me in Russian
like he knows me and say oh let's play
backgammon for money and I was already
like a great way I thought you know why
would you challenge me you know like
everybody is scared and you suddenly
like jump into me I said okay let's play
so we play like 200 euro point or
something and and I was like losing and
a few thousand then my friend like came
and sit down stopped watching the game
for like 10 mins he just told me stop
playing just paid this guy and let's go
you know just I said why I mean like I
obviously see that guy's playing worse
than me and gets very lucky right so I
just paid and we went he said this is
this is a cheater I mean he's the
cheater
he's like like that dies mechanic he
said he he just the way again the way
the cheating been done this firm to my
knowledge over the years it was a couple
of cheating incidents in New York over
the years but it was also involved all
the things that come with bag Amman
which is like it was a guy's board
especially made with some magnets very
heavy board and and his dice also had
magnets which would be more heavier on
like a six for example right when he has
to roll it and he would exchange the
dice during the game you know they were
standing with normal dice with a lot of
money and and somehow it was proved that
he was cheating so he didn't get so the
idea is another way you roll it the idea
is all a magnetic
well that's just one of the things what
are the things I've seen because I
travel around the world night as we
discussed and even probably like 50 plus
countries playing backgammon right and
everybody is different like like for
example I play with some guys in in
Georgia for money and what I know it is
this
during the match before important roles
they would drop in their dice to the
floor right and and I've had to I had to
look down so when I was looking up again
you know they would roll the number and
it was always lucky number in or for
example when they need to hit me right
very important you know shot and then
people told me that this is like
professionals cheating professionals
what they do is when they drop in the
dice and they picking up from the floor
and put it back into the cup they put
only one die back into the cup and
another one they fixing with their with
their finger and when the roll you know
just roll your eyes busy being down
right when you look up the roll already
but they are all only one die and second
one they just put on very quick but
because it requires a lot of skill yeah
but did they put the number which they
need to hit you like then amazing yeah
so but again I play for 20-plus years
right and I've heard like two stories
like that and it never is not uncommon
at all people concern usually with the
internet play both for poker and
backgammon
you know collusion or people can break
into the programs somehow like cheat you
know like be there been couple of
stories with poker backgammon they they
concerned that people use computer to
help them play because you can ask
computer for best decision computers in
backgammon you know there are programs
exist that play on the level of the best
players in the world similar in chess
and just actually in there even stronger
so if you have computer help you know
you have you gain in a huge advantage